Humans have existed for millions of years as part of nature,
but then something changed and in an incredibly short amount of time we tear
formed.
There's Panisse and designed it to fit our needs.
As far as we know,
we're the first beings to awaken and completely take over a planet.
The transition from hunting and gathering to farming and building was so
breathtaking me fast that many of our ways of thinking about the world are no
longer useful.
One of our most outdated ideas is that the most commonly used Canada in the
world insists that we live in the year 2016 this distorts our view of our own
history and makes it harder to understand who we are as a species and just how
far we've come in an incredibly short amount of time.
So maybe it's time to choose a year zero for humanity a year zero that truly
represents us as a species and includes all cultures a year zero.
The marks when we began building our own world on top of the old one
12,000 years ago,
hundreds of humans came together in the hills of southern Anatolia.
They were hunters and gatherers without knowledge of agriculture or
metalworking.
All they had were tools made of stone and wood,
but they built humanity's first big construction project 7,000 years before the
pyramids were built in Egypt,
spread over 300 meters.
Our ancestors erected circles of massive stone pillars,
each of them up to six meters high and 40 tons in weight decorated with artful
pictograms and stone carvings of animals and mythical creatures.
We have no idea how they were able to do this.
It was probably a project of epic scale for the Stone Age requiring a novel of
Organization we didn't know early humans were capable of until we found their
site.
So why did they build it?
The most popular theory is that this was the first temple of humanity dedicated
to non forgotten gods.
We only know that this construction project,
the first of its kind marks the beginning of a new era.
It's in this area around that time that humans truly began to build their own
world,
which would make it a fitting milestone in our history for the start of our
Canada.
This moment in time is so distinct that scientist Chaz Emanyani proposed that
humanity should switch to what he called the Holocene Canada.
By adding 10,000 years to our current Gregorian Canada,
we don't need to change our wet established days.
A month and religious calendars could stay the same as well,
but for all official purposes,
our current year will be the year 12,016 of the human error.
This would drastically alter how we think about history and how it feels.
Let's take a very brief look and move through our new history from our new year.
Zero
12,000 years ago saw the beginning of the first construction project kicking off
our history.
It would be a use for about 2000 years.
It took nearly a millennium until Jericho,
probably the first city on earth was founded in the year 1000 after the start of
the human error,
progress was still very,
very slow.
At this point.
Over the next thousand years,
more and more permanent settlements appeared around the world and more and more
plants and animals were domesticated as agriculture spread evidence for trade
over thousands of kilometers has been found from this period around 5 million
humans were alive at this point in history.
Fewer than live in London today.
Technology advanced constantly at a slow pace.
Pottery became widespread.
The first cultural communities appeared in China,
India,
and the Fertile Crescent around the year four thousand eight thousand years ago.
From today,
humans started to use metal for the first time and learning to mix 10 and cover
and the kickstarting what we know as the bronze age.
Around the year 5,000 the first Proto writing merged and the wheel was invented
in South America.
The Chin Choteau culture started to artificially mummify humans 2000 years
earlier that in ancient Egypt,
the first high cultures began emerging around the year 7,000 the Indus Valley
civilization ancient Egypt,
the Minoans in Greece and the Sumerians in Mesopotamia.
Stonehenge was built in Britain and the first dynasty in China began at see the
iceman lift.
Around this time,
what we consider history now started and things began picking up pace as the
world population rose to over 30 million.
A number of new high cultures appeared around the world.
Many writing down the legends born more cities were founded in South America.
The Omak culture emerged around this time.
The legendary siege of Troy is supposed to have happened soon after in the
eastern Mediterranean and the Fertile Crescent,
the Bronze Age,
and in violence every bronze age culture except Egypt was destroyed by
mysterious invaders.
Writing and progressive froze for hundreds of years around the year 9,500 what
we consider western culture began.
The Greek city states beat off the Persian invasion and triggered that golden
era and it by Alexander the great around (900) 070-0100 years later wrote and
destroyed Carthage and became a dominant force in the wild.
Caesar was murdered in the year 9,956 while the world population had risen to
about 300 million people.
And it's only now around the year 10,000 that we've reached the point where the
Gregorian Canada and our current method of marking human history begins.
Amir,
2000 years from now,
humans will walk on the moon.
If we think about history as we do now,
we are underplaying 10,000 years of human progress and development,
including all of it,
and our Canada makes our past more impressive.
It shows how progress became exponential with time and it incorporates all
humans from all cultures into our Canada.
A New Year zero for our history could reframe how we think of ourselves
as a building project that started 12,000 years ago when for the first time our
ancestors came together to carve a temple out of bedrock with tools made of
stone,
not knowing what they would set in motion,
where it would lead us as a species from building the first temple,
two ships flying beyond the sky.
We've made a coat's cause our diversion of the human error Canada that you can
buy hair if you want.
It's a Canada for 2017 but with one important difference.
It's for the year 12,017 the year we think we should be in.
Right now,
there are only a very limited amount available,
but if we sell,
enough of them will make this a regular thing and maybe produce more print
products in the future.
The calendar is illustrated and we put in a few fun facts.
Also,
as always,
if you like what we do,
please consider supporting us on Patrion vol buying things we made.
It really helps.
Thanks and have a happy 12,017.